in the small Romanian town of SAP enca
when you die you can expect a colorful
farewell death is considered a somber
and even scary thing here in the United
States
funerals are sad Affairs and cemeteries
aren't meant for the living to tread
we've never believed that here at Alice
obscura we celebrate in cemeteries and
consider ourselves pretty deaf positive
if you don't know what that could
possibly mean you should just ask a
mortician but in the small town of SIP
enca Romania they share our views about
death because if you want to see the
humor or joy and dying just take a walk
in the merry cemetery when someone dies
their memory often enters a kind of
idealized state we tell the good stories
about them and not the bad stories if
their death was tragic
we gloss over it we end up with this
kind of tiny version of this person's
life often reduced to as little as rest
in peace on their tombstone not so at
the merry cemetery Stan eeeww patrasche
was born in the small Romanian town of
San pensa in 1908 by the young age of 14
he was already carving the crosses for
the local cemetery by 1935 he was adding
little limericks painting images of the
deceased onto the wooden marker even
sometimes painting the way they died on
to the markers a soldier with his head
being cut off or someone being hit by a
truck he created this kind of folk art
around the deceased on the grave markers
yellow represented fertility green
represented life red represented passion
black represented death sometimes there
was a dub that represented the soul or a
blackbird that would represent a
particular tragic or suspicious death
and was always set against a deep blue
called sap enca blue which he believed
represented not just his hometown but
hope possibility freedom but another
thing that worked its way onto the grave
markers wasn't just this symbolism but
his dark sense of humor one reads here
lies my mother-in-law try not to wake
her up before if she comes back she'll
bite my head off another one says he
loved horses but not as much as he loved
sitting next to someone else's wife at
the bar
patrasche single-handedly carved over
800 of these grave markers it was his
singular vision to make the cemetery a
place that was bright and colorful and
funny and rude and full of life in a way
that very few cemeteries ever are stan
petrus died in 1977 but not before he
carved his own cross painted it and
handed the work to his most talented
apprentice Dimitra pop-pop has carried
on the tradition for the last four
decades and the cemetery has developed a
small museum to go with it despite the
dark comedy or sometimes just dark
themes of the crosses no one has ever
complained they want to see their real
lives represent it if the person liked
to drink you show that if they like to
work you show that it's a small town
there are no secrets people want the
reality as we all know life is messy why
not show that in death as you lived it
in life subscribe here and watch more
videos here and if you haven't actually
checked out ask a mortician you should
it's great it will explain death
positivity a lot about the death
industry we also made a really awesome
video about necro pants if you haven't
learned about necro pants you are in for
a treat